George asks what's your take on
marketing automation software George the
key here is you know I'm not a huge fan
of automation I've talked that up about
that at nause as a matter of fact once
and for all because I keeps coming up
and I know a lot of people are now new
listeners on iTunes if you ever get a
tweet for me or apply to youtube comment
or reply in the Facebook comments like I
did all weekend
it is me there is no outsourcing of my
engagement I had to make a video to
prove it this weekend don't know if you
guys saw that like to prove that it was
me tweeting it is me the way to humanize
automation for people that want to send
out things is the follow up so if you
put something out and you schedule it
not my style I'm against that because
here's what's dangerous about automation
especially in social and email for all
the people I had a lot of friends that I
killed them on this let's go back to a
very sad day the the Boston Marathon
massacre right after that happened over
the next hour to the amount of people
that tweeted promotional by my book
check out my show sign up for my course
my friends I was emailing and DMing them
and saying you were ruining your brand
you are there are 40 people right now
that will never respect you again
because of what you're doing and so in a
world where everything is real-time
scheduling is dangerous for those
anomaly moments where you can look
really bad and don't let mainstream
media pick you up that you're promoting
your book after the president's been
shot or a building's been exploded or a
terrorist act happened because that can
be the end of your career completely to
me that is not worth the upside of the
automation but if you go the automation
route fine here's how you make it human
you act human behind it you put
something out people are engaging with
it you come in humanely and engage it
this will be always a debate that I'm in
a minority which is I want to scale the
unscalable in a world where people are
trying to use modern technology to scale
it's as simple as that
I'm countercultural I'm over here you're
all over here you're all over here I'm
over here and I will stay here because I
believe in it and I believe in it now
because I'm romantic or Zen or or such a
great guy I believe in it
because I think it's sell [ __ ] oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe